what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time or
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us trying to get our lunch money
right
before we start in uniform in uniform i
hope you're in uniform too
tweet at us if you got the black hoodie
or the black t-shirt just tweet at us
and say
hashtag lunch money and i'll go and i
might crack some jokes why does
starbucks still have the christmas cups
because christmas ain't canceled and
everyone knows it
don't forget that lunch money is not
sponsored by block five block five has
three products
they buy and sell crypto on their crypto
exchange you can deposit crypto and earn
up to eight point six percent apy in an
interest-bearing account
or you can deposit crypto take out a usd
loan and get your crypto collateral
go get a black fight account go to block
five dot com slash pomp block five.com
slash
pomp go do it don't
miss out what's up bitcoin had a
big morning
it blew past 48 000 to hit another
record high as major financial firms
warm to the crypto currency
hey listen i know that everyone's
walking around here trying to pretend
like
the bitcoin actually your tie is not the
bitcoin asset
we told y'all we memed and we gift you
all we literally are going to meme our
way to success
we told y'all i've been writing about
this for years
i've been telling y'all she's mad she's
literally kicking me underneath the
table before we started this thing i
said you need to eat some humble pie
that's fine by the way it could all
change tomorrow i fully understand that
but i'm just saying that up to this
point exactly
what we said was gonna happen is
happening
we told you so nobody can act surprised
it could change the circumstances the
environment
the regulatory all that stuff could
change and the future is not guaranteed
past performance is not
an indicator of future performance but
up until now
all right so exactly what we said has
happened
so maybe
bitcoiners actually understand more
about this
asset this network and the economy
better than all the talking heads and
the people on wall street
who are fighting over who got seven or
eight percent returns
bank of new york melon the nation's
oldest bank did you know that is making
the leap into the market
for cryptocurrencies the custody bank
said it will hold
transfer and issue bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies
on behalf of its asset management
clients
this is big isn't it this is very big
it this is part of what sent bitcoin to
an all-time high earlier today
the reason why this is big in my opinion
just my personal opinion
is not only that they are going to do
this that they're going to
custody and transfer assets they're
going to issue stable coins they're
going to do all that stuff
but it's because who their customers are
bny mellon
has public pension funds endowments
hospital systems insurance companies do
you think they did this
as a result of demand from their
customers like it was a bottom-up
push or do you think they are like oh
we're going to be innovative
you can now transfer like bitcoin
i think that they understand that there
is going to be a massive shift the
framework i've used for a long time
before the 70s and 80s we were in the
analog age of assets everything was
physical there was physical stock
certificates physical bonds
physical deeds to your home physical
cash whatever we then
transition to an electronic q-sip world
meaning that when you buy a stock today
you don't get the physical certificate
it's an electronic q-sip that exists in
a centralized database
same thing with your cash right with
your money you don't get physical cash
normally you
92 percent of the money supply is
literally just electronic customs in a
centralized database
all of that is not going to go through
another transition from electronic
accusatives to digital assets
bny mellon fidelity guggenheim jp morgan
goldman
sachs all these massive institutions
they know
that that's happening and what they're
trying to do is they're trying to
position themselves so they can benefit
and be leaders in this new world yeah
but why did they resist it like why did
jp morgan
and jamie dimon resist it then well i
think that one of the things that
uh is definitely a little bit different
is that they were supposed to talk about
bitcoin and cryptocurrency their whole
idea is like you can't break down the
dollar you can't you know whatever
right it's going to be currencies what
they what he missed was the broader
story
he was always a blockchain not bitcoin
guy well guess what
that's the wrong way to be because it's
bitcoin
and then yes there will be digitized or
tokenized
stocks bonds other currencies and
commodities but you can't ignore
the leader in the market and that's what
they're all kind of getting the crash
course on
go ahead so are these banks afraid of
the regulators
no do you think do you think they've
talked to the right okay they're in a
single bank on wall street that's doing
anything without talking to the
regulators first making sure that
they're good to go so why haven't the
regulators
talked about it publicly they have oh
yeah they've already said bitcoin's not
a security they said
uh ether isn't a security uh remember
the market's regulated
if you are in this space and you operate
a business you still have to have money
uh money transfer license you thought to
have a brokered dealer license if that's
applicable you still need to do kyc aml
like
you're still a regulated entity if
you're participating here it's just that
it was a new thing and everyone was
scared of the new thing
well scare money don't make money don't
forget that
uber ceo dara call i can't ever
cause yeah dara the ceo of uber i will
learn to pronounce it when i just don't
like butchering people's names
um said that the company discussed and
quickly dismissed the idea of investing
in bitcoin
but told cnbc the right hailing company
could potentially accept
the cryptocurrency as payment
to which you have to say what
i like the idea that they are open to
the um
concept of accepting it i really
really like him i think he's very
rational but you know that i had to come
in with the windmill 360 dunk
on twitter when they said that they're
not going to put on their balance sheet
and i said
uber has no profits to invest in bitcoin
well he said we're going to keep our
cash safe we're not in the speculation
business i think it makes sense for uber
i think it makes sense for uber as the
ceo so hold on to your cash that's
losing value at an unprecedented rate
when the 1.9 trillion dollars is printed
later this year in the next couple of
weeks 40
4 0 40 of all
dollars in circulation will have been
created in the last 12 months guys
by the way this is what happens when
you're married to somebody like anthony
last night i was sitting at dinner i
didn't tell you this but we were sitting
at dinner
and i was like thinking and what i was
thinking about is
i wonder how like the 1.9 trillion is
just gonna get printed like do you think
there's someone sitting there
and just waiting they're like all right
jim press the button
and he's like all right and then just
like out like how do they do it
well no they it doesn't go out it's all
electronic it's like
going into your bank account imagine if
you go in your bank account you're just
like
control alt delete and you just then
type in a new number
that's what they get but is jim the one
doing it they're like all right
j why are you being sexist maybe it's
sally all right sally get on your
keyboard and edit the number
maybe all right maybe jerome powell goes
and he's
and he's like
and then and then all the central
bankers they all do like a little dance
when he does
exactly what happens right jerome
powell's like
and that's what happens when they when
they do the 1.9 choice let me do that
again 1.9 trillion the central bankers
they get around in the room
and and little uh drone powell
and then everyone else around the world
yeah i
don't know what that dance is
[Applause]
that's what goes on in the central bank
when they create money thank you guys
for tuning in to this very factually
accurate news show
yeah there we go look you can be a
central banker
all right twitter though unlike uber
twitter is considering bitcoin options
including
putting it on its bounce sheet stop
doing that jack
dorsey yeah this is the cfo was saying
this
twitter is considering adding bitcoin to
its company reserves
um et cetera et cetera we have done a
lot of upfront thinking to consider how
we might pay employees should they ask
to be paid in bitcoin
how we might pay a vendor if they ask to
be paid in bitcoin and whether we need
to have a bitcoin on our balance sheet
wait so i have a question yes so what
does it mean to have bitcoin on your
balance sheet does that just mean that
like with all the money that the company
makes
you go and buy bitcoin and then what
and then you just wait for it to
appreciate well hold on a second
the whole idea of bitcoin is you're not
going back to dollars
oh i see so you need to diversify into
the new
well that's one one argument another
argument is that the dollar is literally
just losing value so like
take microsoft he had 500 million
dollars of cash sitting on his balance
sheet yeah
just sitting there what do you do with
it
if it's just sitting there and it's
literally losing value
right it's losing the purchasing power
then what do you do
you have to protect it so you have to
get out of the dollars
is a bitcoin such a volatile asset that
if you go
yes you're protecting it but what if it
goes down the dollar is volatile
they printed 40 percent of all the
dollars in the last 12 months
you all need to pay attention to this
when an asset price goes up that also
means the dollar
is weakening the dollar is volatile
by the way so is bitcoin
all the assets are volatile like we're
out here pretending
just because if we took that logic of
the dollar where
it's just one dollar equals one dollar
and applied it to bitcoin the bitcoins
not volatile
because guess what when you look at it
and you say okay we're gonna take
bitcoin over the dollar guess what's
losing value
the dollar is crashing compared to
bitcoin
just math just math
um all right hold on a second
why are you doing that i'm letting
people know okay the final thing
is i kind of do wish that we knew how
they created the 1.9 trillion like like
that
the ritual that's what i was wondering i
personally hope it's what i just said
but i doubt it
tom brady did a parade on a boat
and then we got a video of him walking
out being
held and walked because he is a little
tipsy
and he retweeted the the quote tweeted
this was very smart of him by the way to
get on top of the story but he quote
retweeted the video of him uh
you know barely walking and said nothing
to see her
he misspelled here nothing to see her
just
little avocado tequila of course it's
avocado because he's healthy
he's spelled in he spotted it all like
like he was drunk that's funny
ah look if you win you get a party
my father used to tell me all the time
you want to know what is fun
winning is fun you want to have fun
playing sports
win that's the way to have fun you want
to have
a bad time then go lose if you want to
have fun
win tom brady won he gets to go have fun
guess who's not having fun the kansas
city chiefs if you want to have fun
win he's a winner he won that means he
gets to get drunk and that means he's
allowed to do whatever he wants you know
who i like though
there's another video of gronk just
dancing it up on a boat he is having the
time of his life i don't know anybody
who has more fun than rob gronkowski
because he wins if you win you get to
have fun
all right oh wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait i'm waiting for you because
now is that now is your moment this is
your moment and
[Music]
ask ellen ask lunch money time
let's do it let's do it all right okay
let's get to it
all right ro sharsh rangoon
hi pomp and pimp i've been checking out
the pump crypto job site thanks for the
resource by the way and have applied to
a couple of
the ops roles that seem to fit with my
background do you have any
recommendations for how
someone without a background in crypto
or tech can make their application stand
out to businesses
in this space uh i don't have any
necessarily any secrets
but what i will say is that i talk to
these companies uh pretty periodically
right now
and there are a ton of people applying
there's a company the other day who went
on
they posted a couple of jobs in the
first three days they had over 200
people apply to the jobs
so there's a lot of people i one thing i
would do
if i was applying for the roles is i
would keep applying the same thing just
go and copy and paste it and just do it
like every day right and so what it does
is like
there's like hey man this guy's replied
like 10 times and maybe we should look
at it i don't know if that's a good
challenge
that's that's something i would do i
would i would personally go try to find
who's hiring for the role on twitter
or somewhere that's how i got my job at
fortune i literally guessed people's
emails from their twitter accounts
i was like it's probably first name
period last name at fortune.com
and i emailed them my resume and stuff
and i was like hey like i'm really
interested in this and because i took
that extra step they gave me
a look yes i completely agree
one other thing i will say is
actually i can't offer that because
people who will use what are you
offering
go to pomcryptojobs.com and you can
apply it's completely free i made it
free for anyone who wants to apply
go apply the companies are all paying
attention there's already a number of
people who've been hired
uh literally one company put up two
roles in the first week they hired one
person they put out a job offer to the
second so like awesome
promise you they're looking please
please please go apply
if uh if you want a job um another thing
i'll say is like
try to tell the people like what you
would how you like what you would change
about there i think we've talked about
this before but like
show what you can do um like why you
would be good for the role by showing
them
thanks paul sierra currently working as
a consultant civil engineering
going into my sixth year in the industry
for a private firm but interested in the
innovation crypto investing markets
how would you make the transition do you
need an assistant slash intern i'll take
the next flight to miami or nyc to help
out
i can't hire everybody he really wants
to though guys he really wants to
i'll build an army and we'll go take on
the world no
uh what i would do is i basically would
go i would look at all the open rules
uh that are on either the job site or
you just go directly to companies
websites
and what i would look at is say okay
here's a venn diagram
here's the companies that i'm interested
in terms of what their mission is what
their product is what they're trying to
accomplish
and then here's the rules that they're
hiring for put those together what's the
thing in the middle that's what i would
go focus on
uh and remember there's two things that
go into these roles one can you do the
job they need and two do you have crypto
knowledge
and so if i was trying to position
myself over the next the next six months
to get a job in
uh the crypto industry what i would do
is i spent a bunch of time learning as
much as i could about crypto
and then i also would spend a bunch of
time just networking like try to meet as
many of the people working at these
companies as possible
and just stay in front of them one of
the keys to getting hired at a company i
always say this is do the job before you
have to do that
that's what i was trying to say with
show them what you can do oh explain
that
well no just like if i'm applying to be
a graphic designer
somewhere like i would redo their site
and
send them a sample and say look at what
i can do yes i don't know how you do
that with crypto but
well it's the same roles right so like a
sales role for example or a business
partnership role
let's say that plato was the hiring
manager and i showed up other than my
good looks obviously you know my
my peaker interest uh i would show up
and what i would say
is um i would say hey so
my thought process is that you guys are
trying to
work with these types of companies i
actually already have
three companies that i've talked to that
would like a meeting could you please
tell me who internally i should
introduce them to
somebody's like well damn like we don't
have to really do the interview because
we know you can do it like you already
got three leads for us
right and so it's that type of stuff
that i think um
really really is valuable for folks uh
in the interview process because it
helps you stand out
it shows that you have a propensity for
action and then on top of it like
you're just being helpful like damn okay
what else can you do
just go your yeah um watch this
anthony when you say peak my interest
how do you spell
peak first of all don't be trying to uh
quiz me like i'm a monkey you quizzed me
on bitcoin the other day
peak p-i-c-q-u p-i-q-u-e
ah dang i'm so close okay
hey how can you know that english is
your second language i know a lot of
languages
i know the language of love okay um
ready so you guys may remember moist
from yesterday
i'm not responding to that voice from
yesterday was saying
day one of commenting on here until pomp
gives me a job yesterday was day one
yesterday was day two you started it yes
are you sure did you
did you check oh i checked and the
people
came and they said let's go moist i'm
rooting for moist
bang bang y'all just unleash the
moisture
and then somebody marco luccini said
i want to take the same challenge as
moist consider this as my comment number
one
it's only for voice only moist is doing
this what did i say
90 days 90 days is a long time do you
want to shorten it no
i might i might extend it if you all
aren't careful 90 days he's got a
comment every day
uh for 90 days and then what did i say i
was going to do
get on a call all right fair lock it in
book it
consider this the receipt for 90 days if
you
comment every day i'll get on a call for
80 88 days from now
no 90 20 yeah
all right so today's day three today is
day three we need a moist counter in the
bottom
that's what we need we're going to need
a moist counter matt and jordy who
edit this we're going to need a moist
counter at the bottom we're on day three
hashtag unleash the moisture okay yeah
all right is that it that's it all right
guys
i just thought of a joke but it's a
kid's show i'm just gonna
keep trucking bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to eight point six
percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account go do your own research there's
risk associated but eight point six
percent is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends